[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
tengo más de 12 años desarrollando
empresas fundando empresas
y hoy decidí confesar algo
soy millonario
tengo más de un millón de dólares
pero no me refiero a mi cuenta bancaria
me refiero a mi cuenta de errores
porque he contabilizado cada uno de los
errores que ha cometido
y mi tiempo emprendiendo no hay nada de
malo con los errores siempre que el
valor de tus aciertos sea mayor
pero qué distinto hubiera sido mi
historia si alguien años atrás me
hubiera contado
todo lo que debía hacer para emprender
con éxito cierto
eso es precisamente lo que ha venido a
compartir con ustedes el día de hoy
pero primero presté atención a la
siguiente estadística
80% de los emprendimientos fracasan en
los primeros
dos años y la estadística es peor aún si
se trata de startups o empresas
relacionadas a tecnología donde cada
diez sólo una sobrevive
pero cuál es la razón de tantos fracasos
yo puedo afirmar desde mi experiencia
que la razón por la que tantos
emprendedores fracasan es que el
emprendedor considera el fracaso como un
acto como una acción en lugar de tenerlo
como un proceso
y cuál es entonces el proceso adecuado
para emprender con éxito lo defino en
tres etapas
prepárate
ejecuta
y triunfa
veamos cada una de ellas
prepárate es todo lo que debes hacer
para emprender
o todo lo que debes hacer antes de
considerar algún día emprender les
cuento un poco de mi historia de
preparación yo cuando ingresé a la
universidad y decidí estudiar ingeniería
tenía que tomar tres cosas y un viaje de
cuatro horas
para llegar a la universidad todos lo
días
logré mi título de ingeniería
y con este título en mano salgo a buscar
empleo
envió 200 hojas de vida por correo
postal
entiéndase correo postal imprimir meter
en sobre crear estampilla e ir al correo
definitivamente eran otros tiempos
cierto
entonces recibo una oferta
era el equivalente al salario mínimo
vigente a la fecha 350 dólares en 1996
para ser más exactos
oferta que yo
con un título ingeniero en la mano
acepté inmediatamente cuál es el primer
mensaje que les quiero transmitir en
este momento
que convertirse en un emprendedor
exitoso batiendo totalmente desde cero
es posible
continúe en la vida laboral
desarrollando conocimientos ganando
experiencia
pero también desarrollando cualidades
hay nueve cualidades que yo considero
que todo emprendedor debe desarrollar
voy a elegir una autoconocimiento
cuántos aquí han escuchado la frase
dedícate a lo que te gusta
casi todo cierto
bueno yo no estoy de acuerdo
porque considero que si lo que quieres
hacer es emprender con éxito
debes dedicarte a aquello en lo que eres
bueno son dos cosas totalmente distintas
y la mayoría de las personas vienen a
confundir las
cuando ustedes nacen tienen habilidades
naturales y otras que van desarrollando
a lo largo del tiempo
si aplican esas habilidades en su
emprendimiento
tendrán una ventaja competitiva
inmediatamente
cuando comento esto siempre me preguntan
los espero
tú cómo sabías
bueno en limpieza porque yo tengo una
empresa limpias
es que acaso era bueno para riendo y
cambiando
y lo confieso no lo hacía mal
pero lo que siempre explico es que mi
empresa
no ofrece
limpieza ofrece procesos eficientes y
eso es algo en lo que yo descubrí que
era bueno observar analizar entender y
mejorar
entiendan que son buenos y sus
probabilidades de éxito de los negocios
aumentarán
para concluir la etapa de preparación
deben encontrar su razón correcta para
emprender
porque existen razones correctas para
tiempo libre
independencia financiera ser tu propio
jefe no son razones correctas para
emprender
son el resultado de haber emprendido
exitosamente quiere saber cómo encontré
mi razón correcta para emprender
yo desde muy joven era muy activo activa
todo tipo de deportes
inclusive uno que ha considerado de muy
alto riesgo para la salud física fútbol
americano
producto de eso a la edad de
30 años sufrió una lesión de columna que
me dejó en cama imagínense ustedes
en cama sin poder moverse
por dos semanas que se hacen
interminables
qué cosas pasan por su mente
volverá a caminar
podré trabajar seré una carga para mi
familia como apoyaré a mi familia eso
muchas cosas más pasaron por mi mente
y fue en ese momento en el que convertí
algo negativo en algo positivo
y lo transformé en mi razón correcta
para emprender
la razón correcta para emprender es
personal cada uno de ustedes la tiene
sólo debe encontrarla
cuando le encuentren pasamos a la
siguiente etapa
ejecuta
esta etapa es importante no solo conocer
conceptos de negocios
si no entender su aplicación le hago un
ejemplo
conocen el concepto penetración de
mercado es un concepto fundamental en
los negocios imagínense que ustedes
inician un proceso una empresa de
fumigación en este momento
y en el mercado al que quieren ofrecer
el servicio en el mercado hay mil
empresas y esas empresas 200 hoy ya le
contratan el servicio de algún proveedor
y las otras ochocientas no se lo
contratan a nadie
200.000 empresas en total son el 20% la
penetración de mercado 20% es el
concepto teórico se entiende cierto
ahora cuál es su aplicación en los
negocios
ayúdame con un ejemplo - ustedes arranca
el empresario y tienen que salir a
ofrecer los servicios quiero que tomen
una decisión de negocios a quien se le
ofrecería a las 200 empresas
que tiene el servicio contratado con
otro proveedor oa las 800 que no lo ha
contratado a nadie levante la mano quien
es el ofrecería a las 200 que lo tiene
contratado con otro proveedor
quienes se le ofrecerían
como ven la mayoría tiene ofrecerlos a
aquellas empresas que no lo tienen
contratado con nadie 'según a salvar
errores que comúnmente veo cometer lo
correcto de ofrecerlo a quienes
lo tienen contratado con otro por qué
muy sencillo
el que no la contrataba es por qué
no lo considera necesario no tiene
presupuesto
esa es la diferencia entre conocer de un
concepto teóricamente y entender su
aplicación en los negocios y ahí es
donde falla la mayoría de los
emprendedores
la tercera etapa
triunfo aquí donde las empresas se
consolidan y crece
este lugar
en un concepto que denomina misión de la
compañía porque emiliano la compañía
porque si lo haces adecuadamente
tu empresa logrará una evaluación de
mercado de un millón de dólares se basa
en tres elementos productos procesos y
personas
pero sus productos productos o procesos
adecuados proceso en procesos eficientes
personas un equipo de trabajo
profesional y comprometido
damos uno de ellos productos
productos te exige
tener un diferenciador
para no tener cumplir por precio y ese
diferenciador de que es ser innovador
pero mi pregunta es es posible
sin ser creativo
yo digo que si llego eso lo hago en base
a mi técnica de innovación basada en ser
porque está compuesto de tres
posibilidades ser el primero
ser el mejor
ser único
le doy un ejemplo
cuando una de mis empresas buscaba un
diferenciador
pero en qué países del mundo esa
industria está más desarrollada y
encontramos que era españa y dentro de
españa evaluamos cuáles eran las
empresas más competitivas y detectamos
que la empresa más competitiva en españa
en esa industria
poseía una certificación de calidad iso
9001 y fue así como convertía mi empresa
en la única
empresas de esta industria en lograr la
certificación de calidad en mi país
es sólo un ejemplo de los múltiples que
pueden utilizar
y entonces
qué pasa si
entiendo que emprender algún proceso
y aplico cada uno de los pasos
como los explicó el resultado será la
evolución exponencial de tus ingresos
la primera línea azul muestra el
crecimiento de los ingresos de una
persona que ha decidido mantenerse
en la vida laboral lo cual no quiere
nada más
crecen de manera lineal constante
una persona que ingresa una empresa a
los 20 años
según los 60
la siguiente línea roja que muestra el
crecimiento de una persona
que ha decidido prepararse para
emprender esta primera etapa de
preparación
vemos que crece también lineal constante
pero a un ritmo más lento
por qué
porque en esta primera etapa sacrificas
ingreso por conocimiento
luego viene lo que llamo la montaña rusa
cuando decides emprender tu ingreso cada
cero hay gentes
mariposa en el estómago
tengan náuseas ganas de vomitar
yo siempre explico que el momento más
difícil aquí
no es el día que renuncia de hecho
satisfacción sientes no
o te quedas sin empleo el momento más
difícil o no decías emprender es
exactamente 15 días después
cuando llegas al banco
nadie me depósito efe el momento mágico
pero si has hecho las cosas
adecuadamente
sus ingresos empiezan a crecer
lentamente al inicio hasta llegar al
punto donde estarías e ingresos si
tuviera mantenido en la vida laboral
y la última línea en la que llamo la
línea del triunfo
los ingresos empiezan a crecer de manera
acelerada
exponencial sin límites
aquella vez aquí es donde ves todos tus
sacrificios y tus esfuerzos
materializadas
quiero dejarlo con un mensaje personales
a lo largo de la vida me han preguntado
si me considero
un hombre exitoso como de fino éxito
yo siempre respondía no
que me faltan
muchas metas por lograr
hasta que un día dije
me considero un hombre exitoso
por qué
no por la cantidad de empresas que funda
24 en dos países
no por las ganancias que generan esas
empresas
sino por la cantidad de empleos miles de
empleos que he logrado generar a lo
largo de más de una década
lo cual me ha permitido mejorar la
calidad de vida de muchas personas
el camino del emprendimiento
es difícil si lo reconozco pero es muy
gratificante
si ese es el que deciden seguir
asegúrense
de disfrutar el proceso
[Aplausos]
[Música]